first of all can we just be clear about
one thing uh this week in that vote on
uh the
covet strategy or covid tactics will you
be supporting the government's plan b
we've consistently put public health
over party politics so yes we will be
because we do need to protect public
health
it looks uh from what we've been reading
and indeed from what the secretary of
state uh
said for education said this morning
talking about the extraordinary
exponential
growth of omicron that they will have to
go further will you support
a plan c
for example a further lockdown
well before any additional restrictions
should even be contemplated we've got to
see government urgently
taking a number of actions they should
be boosting the booster program we're
far behind where we need to be we
haven't seen those retired staff being
pulled back in those volunteers being
pulled back in for the booster like we
saw initially that's got to happen now
we need to see action on our schools
we've got less than half of the young
people who should have been vaccinated
by now actually having been vaccinated
the government doesn't seem to have any
uh plan for ventilation in schools all
they're saying to teachers is just open
the windows we'll try doing that in
december in lots of parts of our country
and of course they haven't fixed sick
pay either so there's a huge amount the
government must do must do urgently and
they must do that before they even
contemplate looking at any additional
restrictions this is very urgent now
so ventilation
uh a bigger drive for jabs for young
people and so on um you wouldn't go any
further at this point for example
extending vaccine passports
well we really need to get those other
measures in place because we know that
ultimately the vaccine
is the strongest barrier against this
disease progressing particularly with
the omicron variant there we've got to
boost that booster program that's going
to be the strongest defense
as you know trevor we've got those plans
that will be coming through around the
vaccination of nhs
staff now actually we want to see
government working very very hard as the
welsh labour government has done
actually to make sure that nhs staff
have all the information about the
vaccine that there's a really strong
education and encouragement program
there that will drive up uptake if
ultimately that doesn't get us far
enough then we will not oppose a
passport scheme for those nhs
staff uh but really government should be
learning from what's worked elsewhere
and the conservatives seem to be
unwilling to do that even though those
education and encouragement programs
have been so successful in labor on
wales
there's one there's one estimate that
says that the nhs could lose more than a
hundred thousand staff because of um
mandatory vaccines uh you would still
insist
that nhs staff had um were required to
have vaccinations at some point if uh
persuasion doesn't succeed
well the government has set out a
timetable of this beginning in april so
they've got a number of months to really
focus
on that education and encouragement and
you know this is not about remaking the
wheel as i said they've got a very good
example coming from cardiff with the
welsh labour government there where they
worked incredibly hard to get the
message out to combat this information
to make sure also the vaccination was
very very easy for nhs staff
to
take part in and that drove up those
levels you know they're significantly
higher amongst nhs staff in wales
compared to in england that ultimately
is what should be focused on but if it
doesn't get us as far as it needs to the
evidence that we've seen suggest that
mandatory vaccinations for the nhs staff
may have to still be on the table in
april so we're not going to be arguing
against it for the sake of it
all right let's turn to the politics do
you
have confidence in the proposed or the
um ongoing cabinet secretary
investigation
into christmas parties and all of that
well i wish it was into christmas
parties and all of that because it isn't
an investigation that we'll be looking
into all of the different parties that
we've seen evidence of no more well
actually i think they announced
yesterday that they were extending it
well i am encouraged if they genuinely
are because until recently the
suggestion was it would only cover
effectively one party but frankly of
course this is going even beyond number
10 because we have now heard that there
have been
social events which for example the
former education secretary took part in
so we've got to have full transparency
around that now the prime minister must
make sure that he is very open about
everything that he knows just a few days
ago the prime minister suggested he knew
nothing about any parties and then he
ordered an inquiry into one of them
that's a very strange set of affairs and
i think british people are really fed up
with all of this chaos with all of the
sleaze that's engulfing the prime
minister he's got to get a grip now and
our country's facing massive challenges
they need a government that actually is
adequate to face up to those challenges
rather than one that's just engulfed in
sleaze
are you um
is it a time for labor to be calling for
the prime minister to stand down at the
time of national crisis
wouldn't that be a non-partisan thing to
do
well obviously i'm a labour mp so from a
partisan point of view now i'm working
every day to try and get a new
government in place to try and get the
conservative government out but when it
comes to the prime minister's position
that's ultimately in the hands of the
conservative party and i do want them
yeah but come on come on
you've been telling us how important
this is for the country that you're
you're interested in the country rather
than party we have a leader that your
own leader says is not fit for office
and this is not a party political thing
we need a prime minister who's going to
lead us through this crisis surely if
you really believed that you would be
saying it is time for boris johnson to
resign and allow somebody who can lead
the country uh effectively to take uh
the keys to number 10. so is it time for
boris johnson to stand down or not
we've been very very clear that he's
unfit for office but ultimately the
resignation of a conservative prime
minister is in the hands of the
conservative party not the hands of the
labour party and what we've been urging
week after week month after month
is for this conservative party to get a
grip because for as long as it doesn't
get a grip working families in our
country continue to pay the price